[Music]
LEED is different from other online
courses because it really gives you a
lot in terms of interaction with your
peers teaching assistants but mostly
with the professors that interaction
with the professor's to me is what
completely sets LEED apart from other
online courses never have I faced an
issue where I wanted to reach out to the
faculty but I was not able to and they
were pretty responsive and kind enough
to answer my questions with elaborate
answers when I got exposed to difficulty
that Stanford is famous for it was
beyond impressive there's a lot of cases
where you had live sessions and you
could obviously communicate that way but
there was also a lot of discussions in
the forums or even one-on-one email
dialogues so you definitely had a lot of
support and you felt pretty connected to
and engaged and committed to the classes
you have access to this information and
also this exchange is in such enriching
experiences that any other program did
not experience often I've actually used
case studies or questions that I got the
day before or that I saw the day before
in the lead program and then I would
come across something at work and I
could immediately apply it the courses
are designed such that they give you the
right tools techniques and framework
which you can take and apply in your
career you can do it at your own pace at
your own convenient time LEED is
probably the best learning experience
they can get outside an MBA they're
interested in learning about business
and leadership practices it's not so
much about the the certificate or the
degree it's much about the skills that
are kawaii here